Stanford University
Hello, I'm Olav Solgard. And I'm here to tell you about our graduate
certificate program in data models and
optimization. The purpose of this
certificate is to teach you how to solve
big, complex problems. How to let the
computer do that job for you. How do you
program the computer to solve these
very connected problems that has
large amount of data in them. How do you make
sure that you not only solve the problem, but that you found the best possible solution.
Like many of our certificate
programs, this program is also built with
a set of foundation courses. That
foundation is your algebra
and statistical learning and statistical
methods. Those allows you then to really
understand how you formulate big
problems with a lot of interconnected data,
but you still also need to find out how
do you optimize? Meaning, optimize a
solution. You can find solutions that
will work, but are they best ones? This is
what we're going to be going into. And
then when you really really getting
excited about your foundational
techniques, now your going to be able to apply them.
One of the areas you will apply them to is in finance. Another one is
data mining. And then there is complex design, or design of complex systems.
Any industry that is engaged with big
data, and that is really a wide range
of industries these days.
Any industry like that, ah, we really need to have people
who are experts on optimization
and models, which is what we teaching in
this particular certificate.
Once you've taken these courses, you will actually
start thinking about problems in a
different way. You will actually change.
You will be different because you
have a different perspective and a
different tool that you can use to solve
problems. Yeah, I guarantee is it's gonna
change you.